I think it's accessibility uh comes down
to that because that way you get access
to like what you really want not just
what you have available around you and
that's the biggest difference of it
because if you say hey I want to buy
this product and it's made in New York
but I live in Miami mhm then you you
just have it accessible you go online
you buy it and it shows up to your
doorstep before that it was like okay I
want to buy this product but this is
made in New York I'm not really going to
go to New York right now so like what's
similar to these around me in Miami so
that whole like
accessibility um question I think is
what marks the biggest difference on
what this used to be you know 10 years
ago versus what it what is it now
mhm all right guys bang bang I've got
Juan here with me uh I thought a great
place to start is you've taken a
business from Z in Revenue to eight
figures in a little over a year which is
not normal whatsoever uh what are some
of the Lessons Learned when you are
hyper growing like this I mean I think
the the the first place to start is how
do you build a team to do this you know
at the end of the day like it all falls
down on your team no matter what you're
doing um in terms of a business like
yeah you know you can start a business
and and run it Smalls a few million
dollars in Revenue but like if you
actually want to go to hyper growth and
only have these as a beginning of your
business you need to build the team to
be able to support that and then the
company culture as well so so you know
as an example company values company
values is huge for us like we leave and
breathe our company values so as an
example we have you know being customer
obsessed as an example like you don't
know how much we care for our customers
what's the craziest thing you guys have
done on that front I mean like this is
um not necessarily a crazy thing but
like this is a funny story is sometimes
people internally refer to us as a
company instead of a SAS as a Cass which
means company as a service because we
literally will do like anything for our
customers like we go so beyond for our
customers like you know we need them to
be profitable we need them to be
successful we need them to be having
like the experience of their lives
working with us we need like their
customers to be extremely happy as well
given how much you know impact we have
in their actual operation so um you know
as we make make fun of it internally we
say Hey you know we're not a SAS we're
not a 3PO we're just a cast a company as
a service so what you guys do uh for
those who don't know is um
logistics for perishables so food
flowers uh could be medicine Etc um some
people would refer to this as kind of
cold chain part of the supply chain uh
and what I didn't know before I met you
and and eventually invested in business
is there's tons of people who are
focused on legistics obviously Amazon's
a massive business they don't want to
touch perishables right because it
spoils because there's all these issues
and so walk me through your time of
butcher box like how did you actually
learn about the problem and then figure
out what these potential Solutions are
yeah I mean perishable is as hard as it
gets um it's very expensive and it's
very time sensitive and there's a lot of
risk throughout the whole equation
because if you don't deliver things to
your customer how you need to then
they're just not going to buy from you
again you're just not going to provide a
good service uh if you're buying a
t-shirt in the mail as an example you
know not perishable of course you know
you might want it for a party sure you
might get it a day late and you're not
happy because you wanted it for this
party but you still have a t-shirt you
can wear it like it's fine but in the
case of perishables it's usually
something you're eating something you're
feeding your family with like a party
you're hosting that you know you need
the products for pharmaceuticals which
could be you know life- saving or very
important for someone's health or it
could be flowers and you know you don't
want to mess up a flower delivery right
because you're going to get someone uh
pretty mad so you know at butcher box so
you know for those that don't know the
story bootstrap company scale from Z to
600 million Revenue um you know pretty
fast in about six years um so arguably
want to like uh you know the most
successful director consumer companies
in the space you know in the last like
decade or so and the interesting part
about it is that 10 years ago or eight
years ago when we were start getting
started with that perishables in the
mill was not a thing was like you know
we had to get over the hump of hey you
buy a box of frozen meat and it shows up
to your doorstep Frozen like you know
what the heck how how does this even
happen so early days a butcher boxy was
like Hey how do we get people to buy a
box of frozen meat in the mail and now
Through The Years consumer Behavior has
changed because they now know this like
consumers know hey I can get online you
know as an example butcherbox.com I buy
a box of meat and it one or two days it
shows frozen to my doorstep so with that
changing consumer behavior of course
there's a lot more demand in this
industry and there's a lot more Brands
and products that have come alive um you
know in the last decade or so and with
that comes a problem hey you know how do
I solve for this like there's so many
factors that go into it like you know
weather events Sky performance what
liners am I using what type of box when
am I shipping it where am I shipping it
from what type of product is it like so
many variables that go into it that you
really need a sophisticated solution to
be able to like go from point A to point
B and make your customer happy the way I
think about it is like uh people didn't
know 10 15 years ago you could press a
button on your phone and a non-p
perishable could get uh to your doorstep
right so a book from Amazon or or
whatever now I mean a lot of people do
it lot like you know in New York City if
you go and you look in the lobbies
around Christmas time they look like
Amazon warehouses there's just tons and
tons of boxes right people ordering
things then the next iteration was I can
press a button on my phone and hot food
will show up and once I start to
understand it's like oh yeah the guy
down the street made it and somebody
just brought it to me but what you guys
really are are identifying is like
there's now a third wave to this trend
which is I'm going to press a button on
my phone and cold food will show up
whether refrigerated or Frozen and so
what are the things that people are
doing with that like obviously butcher
box is meat are people shipping cakes
are they sh like what are the other
products that really are getting shipped
here yeah I mean you touch you a good
point this gives accessibility to the
market and Market being the consumer who
wants a product at their house because
you can only like you can only keep foot
warm for so long right like you know
maybe 30 minutes while it gets in the
you know overheats or whatever other
platform to your doorstep but the cold
and the Frozen what this creates is you
can now have inventory in specific
location across the country and you can
get your product Nationwide like you can
make a product here in New York City and
you can have it nationwide like the
impact that that has you know for so
many different products that you can
make so of course you know you have meat
you have Frozen ready to eat meals you
have you know desserts and Cake products
you have Pharma you know you have things
of course like you know like flowers
which is which is a you know semi
different category but you have a wide
range of Specialty Products even you
know human great pet food which is you
know a pretty fast growing uh space and
wildly adopted across the country but
like that's what has changed you can now
basically press a button and you get a
box of something perishable so Frozen or
refrigerated in your doorstep and you
know with a few distribution centers
across the country then you can get to
anywhere in the country in one and two
days with the right technology of course
and the right processes for making that
happen but you know think about someone
that used to deliver a warm food to new
New York City and that was their market
and they could only Market you know to
this market and they could only sell on
this market and now all the sudden you
know they get this thing called and they
can keep it called for a few weeks or
you know a few months and you can just
get it nationwide it's it's just like
the whole movement is insane what's so
interesting to me about this is um if
you go back in history right and I I
like to fancy myself having read about
history uh food was never preserved
right and until the invention of either
freezing or refrigerating the food there
was no ability to actually preserve food
through time and so by being able to now
freeze or refrigerate all of a sudden
you could have uh food throughout
different seasons you could you know
ship it places there's all these things
that got unlocked by just bringing
refrigeration and uh kind of freezing
technology to the market MH in some
weird way it's like history is repeating
itself again right and now you're saying
wait a second we are going to take that
same exact You Know lesson from history
and now apply it to this whole new world
where frankly there's you know a
gazillion restaurants in anyone
geography but if they've been previously
just kept you know local you now can
make them in this case National maybe
eventually globally as well yeah totally
and and you know there's this concept of
like flash freezing for example and you
flash freak you flash freeze at the peak
of freshness what is that that means
that you know like you literally like at
the moment where the food is at the
freshest point then you basically run it
through an extremely fast very cold
freezing process and you conserve the
freshness you know some things change in
the food but you conserve the freshness
so when something is not frozen it
basically keeps deteriorating over time
always so if you have fruit for example
and you don't freeze it then you know
two weeks three weeks it's not eatable
anymore but if you like flash freeze it
peck of freshness and then you basically
you know thigh it and then you eat it in
the next day it's like as fresh you know
as it gets of course you know when
you're speaking about something that has
been um you know Frozen before so even
when you speak about that like
conserving food at that point and making
sure that like through the entire value
chain when you know storing process
packing process Logistics process
getting to someone's doorsteps process
like if it's kept if the temperature is
kept to that point then you know goes
back to what you're saying which is like
hey you know conserving food and getting
it nationwide it's like a whole other
level right now across Across the Nation
so what is the business that you guys
are in like explain in terms of you guys
have warehouses uh I believe you have a
billion dollars wor of goods that have
kind of gone through the network like
I'm a customer of grip who am I and like
what am I interfacing with or what am I
getting from you so yeah so let me give
you some some history on these so when
if if you were a perishable director
consumer company you know five years ago
basically you had to figure out
internally the back half of your
business which is hey I create an
amazing product I sell it through a
point of sell system now how do I get it
to the final customer which you know all
these companies that have amazing
products are not necessarily logistics
companies like it's a you know different
worlds so what we do which is a lot of
just real quick and on that what you're
basically saying is like if you were
selling I don't know bookstands you
could focus on the product somebody
orders it you just hand the bookstand to
FedEx and and you're good to go but now
once once it's perishable FedEx and
others may not want to take it you may
have to change the the processor like
like there's complexity with the
perishable that changes what maybe
normal business goes through this
episode is brought to you by bet online
do you like making a profit from sports
betting well set yourself up to take
home the most profit possible using
crypto to fund your sports betting
casino and poker account at
betonline.ag you can avoid costly
transaction fees get your payouts
lightning fast and do it all securely
and anonymously with the highest deposit
and withdraw limits in the industry if
you want to get in on the action do it
the smart way with crypto at
betonline.ag head to the website sign up
with promo code pomp 100 to get 100%
bonus on your crypto deposit today if
you go and you deposit they'll give you
100% bonus if you use promo code pomp
100 bet online go where the game starts
betonline.ag go check them out today
totally I mean they they they they take
it but you focus on what you can control
which is okay who am I giving it to when
it comes to the carriers and then how
much refrigerant am I adding into the
box and then what you know how much
insulation am I sending this with and
where am I sending it from so like you
focus on the variables that you can
control and then you give it to the
carrier or shipping service that data
says that performs the best to that
specific C with that specific product
and then you get it to the final
consumer so you know what what I was
saying in terms of the history is 5 10
years ago you had to try to either build
all these complex internally which means
spending you know $10 million internally
trying to build and maintain the systems
or you would basically just give it to a
shipping carrier and hope for the best
without necessarily focusing on on what
you can control so what we've done now
is we basically have like connected all
these different data points to say hey
focus on your product like focus on your
sales focus on your branding on your
marketing and what you can actually do
best and then let us do the rest it's
similar to like when you work with a
company like stripe for example where if
you're running a director consumer
company right now and you're trying to
recreate to rebuild stripe like good
luck you know why why are you spending
your resources doing that so with us
it's basically like Hey listen focus on
what you can uh control on your end and
focus on what matters for your business
and then you basically send the product
to us so send the inventory to us once
you sell something flows into our
systems we run it through what we call a
shipping engine which figure out what's
the absolute best way to get it to the
final customers and then we get it to
your final customer so it's like
basically the full back end of it now
when we first met um you had done this
at butcher box figured all this out and
you realized everyone else was going to
need to do this as well um and one of
the things that you use as an example is
weather alerts and how weather could
delay a shipment and that would change
the decision- making of what you put in
the Box describe maybe an example in
terms of like how does theof software
tell people like oh [__] weather you
know bad weather could potentially
disrupt This and like what are the
changes people are making as they're
actually creating the box with the goods
to send to the customer major weather
events and perishable products you
combine those two is a good way to get
gray
hair very good you want you want to Fast
Track your way towards gray hair like
combine those two um and that's because
like there's let's say there's a wild
fire in California and you know you're
shipping 10,000 boxes to California this
week and if if you just like basically
don't have someone checking you know
weather page.com and trying to make
those decisions and trying to figure out
like what's going on with the major
weather events and the wildfires and
your boxes then you can very easily just
have like $100,000 on the road just you
know like good luck um so that's like
one of the biggest changes and things
that we went for just because for me was
so stressful when I was managing this
where we were trying to basically match
we had a guy internal a butcher box we
used to call the weatherman which it was
like Hey you know your job is to go to
weather.com and figure this out um you
know those resources could be better
spent of course doing more value added
activities but it it goes back to like
hey you're shipping 100 you know boxes
or a th000 buckes or 10,000 whatever the
number is like how do you proactively
know that the route of that box is going
to be impacted by a major weather event
and then you proactively reach out to
the customer and say hey we're about to
ship your a box we notice it's impacted
by a major weather event do you want us
to hold it you know cancel the shipment
send it in two days or 3 days after the
major weather event is gone you
basically just like took a bad
experience flip it on the head and make
it a very good one for your customer
because if you know I'm shopping on a
brand and with a brand and they send me
an email or text saying that I'm like
okay these people have their [__]
together now um what if they say not
send
it I mean some some companies are are
you know risk diverse some some are not
some are basically hey you know we know
we send it and now we're going to also
send communication to the customer
basically saying hey if something's
wrong let us know we'll make it right
for you but at the same time like having
that information to make it right for
the customer it's where basically the
data uh matters now as you uh kind of
see this play out maybe what is the most
surprising things right I mean again
super fast growing business uh one that
you already understood kind of what to
build but now you got to go build it for
other people not just a company that
you're working at um what have been the
biggest surprises
I wouldn't
say I mean not necessarily like a a big
surprise but it's a reminder and and
this is what we started talking about of
like how much your team matters because
like at the end of the day you only have
your team to build a company so everyone
needs to be committed to building what
we're building here which is a once in a
generation company and going like all in
on that and that means you know like
long hours that means a lot of effort
that means like thinking outside the box
that means going the extra mile that
means like always delivering A+ work and
like as I'm saying not necessarily a
surprise because you know kind of knew
that going into this and and from my
time at butcherbox as well but you know
I'm always like you know reminded about
that like every time I see that the team
working so hard now where are you
finding these employees like are is
there a certain Arch type that you're
looking for are there certain
backgrounds that you're you're going for
you just looking for you know smart
hardworking people how are you putting
this team together
ER smart hard workking people for sure
that's we need that um but through know
one of the goals for this year or or one
of the things that we're focusing on
this year is uh defending our company's
culture and I say defending because you
know we've built a pretty good company
culture and now we have to defend it as
we 2x 3x and 5x the team so one of the
things that we do for finding these
people is through the interview process
every single person that's going to
interview a candidate they get one
company value and their job through this
interview process is to screening this
person for this one company value so
that's something that basically if one
person in the team you know raises a
hand and says like hey I don't think
that they pass the you know Relentless
improvement company value we're like
okay you know we're not hiring this
person so that's you know that doesn't
necessarily answer the question of like
what's the source of these people but
the the the framing that we use for
hiring people is Hey how well can they
get come in here and how well can they
play within our company values and
culture so like Relentless Improvement
is one of the company values how do you
screen for that I mean there's like
multiple questions that uh you can ask
someone but when it comes to Relentless
Improvement as an example we work
internally with what we call fast
Innovation Cycles which means that
nothing has to be perfect for launching
but you work very close with a customer
and then you go from idea to product to
feedback very fast so we ask for example
for situation of hey you know when have
you involved when have you been involved
in launching your product and like guide
us through the full um like I just to
the full cycle of launching that product
um you know something that we don't do
internally is lock ourselves in a room
for six months work on something
thinking that we're building what's
right and then go and try to launch it
like we bring the customer in day one
and we get feedback from them day one
and we launch with them you know day one
basically so we try to screen for those
things you know asking for a situ where
they've been involved in in you know
Building Product like that and when
you're going through this process how
much of it is you're interviewing them
versus trying to sell candidates on
joining like it's a little bit of a
dance right between you're trying to
screen but you also if you get them to
the end you don't want them to be like
man these people are [__] and I
don't want to work here right so how do
you balance that um I mean we I'm very
blunt through the hying process and I
basically shoot straight with hey this
is how it's like to work here so it's
it's It's tricky because at the same
time you don't want to scare people away
too much but if you actually do then
that means that that was probably not
you know the right person to to work in
the company but uh as you say you know
it's a dancing Act of like hey getting
someone excited to build an industry to
innovate within an industry but then
getting them to understand like how hard
it actually is and how many sacrifices
you you have to do you know on a
personal level on a um you know like the
work balance level
so yeah I mean you're right it's it's
it's definitely you know a balancing
night between those two now um you all
have physical locations as well you
these warehouses talk a little bit about
uh maybe the benefits and the downsides
to you know many software companies
they're just like hey we write software
uh we have office right um you guys have
warehouses you're Ming you're moving
physical products like like there's a
lot of complexity here and I think a lot
of software entrepreneurs would look at
this and be like that's not a business I
want to be involved in does that
actually a competitive Advantage because
it's hard or are there other downsides
that that maybe they are right
on that's what I want to be involved in
like if someone says hey I don't want to
be involved in that like that's that's
where we come in and that's where we add
value because like software can be very
pretty and software can you know look
beautiful and and it can do some things
but it's really mostly valuable when you
get that to connect with the physical
world mhm and when you get the software
to basically like have the hand inside
how the goods move through the through
the physical world that's where you
basically like you know 1 plus one does
not equal two that's where you now
basically like exponentially increase
the the like the value of an industry
and and the benefits of like you know
working with a provider like you and and
a lot of people scare away from it and
and maybe they're just like not not
build for that and and maybe you know
maybe it's not the type of company that
they're trying to build but the way that
we are approaching the solution we need
to have our hands you know inside the
process because there can't be any data
holes mhm like if you basically ship the
orders or the software says Hey ship the
orders this way but then you basically
don't know where your orders are you
know within the next 5 hours or 10 hours
then that's a hole that you need to get
visibility into because that impacts
your uh in customer experience so that's
why like that's where we want to be
involved because that's where the whole
happened mhm Now what is like the North
Star here right like like how big can
this get what does it look like you know
5 10 years from now when you kind of
wake up and you're like this is where
we're going what is that what is that
path so I mean to this point we're
definitely the most Innovative company
in the space ER we um are taking these
you know very seriously from a
Innovation Improvement and like A+
customer experience standpoint so you
know in 5 years from now we're
definitely going to be like the company
known in the space for this whole thing
and the this means that you know as I
was saying before if you're a company
that ships direct to Consumer products
perishable which means refrigerated or
Frozen then you focus in that and we are
the company that you trust for the back
half of that so basically you providing
the infrastructure for all these DDC
companies now um there's a bunch of DDC
companies I could rattle off right now
off the top of my head that ship things
that are uh perishable um how much of
the future business is going to people
who have perishables but don't ship and
saying to them hey you should be
shipping right kind of hey right now
setting this stuff in New York City but
actually you could do it nationally let
us help you do it yeah it's a
combination and we see you know a big
value at them both because we work with
a very big retailers that they don't do
it because they haven't been able to do
it like they don't have the technology
they don't have the resources to be able
to do this so it's an interesting mix of
customers because the the retail the big
retailer has already figured out the
product itself and they have the
resources for the marketing and people
know their brands pretty well but but as
I was saying before that's very
different from becoming a logistics
company so they haven't taken a step at
becoming a logistics company and that's
where there's a very big opportunity
where they basically just you know have
these as another massive um you know
sales channel for them on the other hand
you have you know the companies that are
already at you know multi-million dollar
companies like a butcher box would be
where you know this is just a massive
value ad versus what they're doing
internally because one they can use
resources for something else and then
two you know I was giving this stripe
example like know if you try to build
strip you're never going to be as good
as them for payment processing or some
other company that does this because
like that's the whole the only thing
that they do that's what they focus onh
now when you start looking at um the
other competitors in the space you said
that you're the most Innovative uh many
people may think oh there's another
technology company doing this but
actually most of these are 50 100
year-old companies have been doing this
for a really long time what are some of
the main differences between working
with like a an incumbent that is a big
company but slow moving bureaucratic and
kind of like outdated from technology
versus with you from the customers
perspective like are there very obvious
you know things where maybe in another
industry it's like hey this guy's got a
fax machine this guy's got email right
but like what is it in this uh specific
vertical this episode is brought to you
by cal.com what do I have in common with
Chad Hurley from YouTube Toby from
Shopify and Alexis from 776 and the
co-founder of Reddit we all use cal.com
instead of Cly we are all early
investors as well cal.com is leading the
charge of scheduling Platforms in the
open-source sphere offering you the
chance to harness the efficiency
previously reserved for League
corporations and Tech gurus if you like
to have your calendar organized and be
able to have an efficient exchange when
scheduling but you love all of the
benefits of open- source technology then
cal.com is for you they are transforming
sophisticated calendar management into
an accessible tool for all via a
userfriendly interface you can customize
it and you can make your calendar work
for you use code pomp for $500 off when
you set up your team with cal.com today
again go to cal.com
cal.com and use code pomp to get $500
off when you sign up cal.com an open
source tool that allows you to take back
control of your calendar be efficient
when scheduling and make sure that no
one can steal your time so how the
industry evolved is you know Frozen
storage companies usually do pet in
Pallet out which means you bring a truck
with a pet of product for clip downloads
the pallet gets counted or you know
verify that it's the right product gets
put in the freezer and then sometimes
they pick a case of that specific
product and ship it out or most of the
times they take that same pet and they
get it somewhere else so basically
petting pet out the industry over the
last years have innovated and has been
forced to move into the eaches what we
call it which means hey you now take the
pallet you open it up up and you
actually grab the product and put it
into the box that is going to go to the
final customer so it's not the pallet
being moved and it's not even the crate
that's being moved is actually the
individual skew is getting picked up
correct so and and the industry has been
evolving into that because of the you
know direct to Consumer offering that
has been also coming up coming up online
over the last few years but you know it
it's a very different offering when it
comes to pet in pet out to the eaches
and then getting that to the final
consumer because of how much more
complex it is from a variable standpoint
of how many more things you have to do
and then how much more data you need to
actually do it right so you know there's
great companies from um like a
warehousing and storage space that have
been forced to move into this but that's
just a one small piece of the puzzle
like when you take that and you add
technology and much more scanning and
data to that and you interconnected them
with hey what happens before that and
then what happens after that which means
before that is say how do I decide how
to send this box and then after that how
do I Monitor and how do I control how
that box is getting delivered to my
final customer that's the biggest
difference uh in the
space What are some of the numbers you
can share in terms of like how big these
markets are right so you said that
you've overseen a billion dollars worth
of goods already which is to me like
that's massive number um you scaled the
business in a little over a year from
zero to eight figures of Revenue how big
is the market like do these businesses
do tens of billions of dollars in
revenue or or what I mean multi-billion
dollar market um for sure you have when
you split it up you have basically the
the like the direct to Consumer milk
companies which is a multi-billion
dollar market then you have the
Specialty Products which is multibillion
dollar market and within this you have
like you know things interesting as like
frozen pizza from Chicago like there's
thousands of people across the country
that you know buy frozen pizza from
Chicago on a daily basis and that's a
multi-billion dollar market by itself
then you know flowers like five plus
billion dollar market and then you have
the whole Pharma industry which is you
know insulin in the mail it's basically
shipping that in the mail is very
similar to shipping you know a piece of
refrigerator or you know Frozen
something other the product in the mail
so that within within itself is also a
billion dollar market so when you
combine all these things you know you're
talking about multibillion multi-billion
dollar market and like let's say uh the
pizza from Chicago the people who are
selling that how many of them are like I
have a pizzeria in Chicago it's good
pizza and I figured out how to sell
online versus somebody in Chicago is
like man none of the people who have you
know pizza poers here in Chicago know
how to sell online so I'm going to
create like a brand and it's like Frozen
only right versus no this is just an
extension of an existing brand It's a
combination I mean if you have a brand
that people already recognize and you
open the market to the Nationwide that's
just you know just like so many more
sales that you can get through the same
market like through the same people and
Nationwide but then you you also have
the people that basically say Hey you
know pizza from Chicago has a massive
like you know ring to it and people know
it you know deep dish pizza a lot of
people love it so I'm just going to
build that and focus on that because I
know that they want I can get Nationwide
coverage so you see both for sure
because if you have a very recognized
brand like why not getting Nationwide MH
and how much of this is like consumer uh
changes right so like butcher box is a
good example where um obviously people
want to get meat they're going to go to
the grocery store they go to you know
Costco whatever um but there was like it
gets delivered in the mail there's a
subscription element to it and also was
like healthier food and so is that more
so like the offering is so compelling or
is it no the consumer is just going to
go on their phone and order stuff and
like you got to be there and if you're
not there they're going to order from
somebody else I think it's accessibility
uh comes down to that because that way
you get access to like what you really
want not just what you have available
around you and that's the biggest
difference of it because if you say hey
I want to buy this product and it's made
in New York but I live in Miami M then
you you just have it accessible you go
online you buy it and it shows up to
your doorstep before that it was like
okay I want to buy this product but this
is made in New York I'm not really going
to go to New York right now so like
what's similar to this around me Miami
so that whole like
accessibility um question I think is
what marks the biggest difference on
what this used to be you know 10 years
ago versus what it what is it now mhm
and when you think about Lessons Learned
at butcher box that you are replicating
with grip what's like maybe the biggest
one or two outside of the team like just
hey I got to have a high quality team
but what what are some of the other
lessons that you're you know I have to
make sure I implement
this um I think having a a mentality of
getting things done now like an urgency
urgency correct correct urgency
because like often times companies fall
into this trap that they talk about
initiatives and they talk about projects
and Innovations for months and months
and months or weeks without necessarily
acting acting on it so um you know one
of our company values is actually you
know biased towards action and that
means that we go into a meeting and if
we chat about something or we discuss
something we do not leave that meaning
until the next step is figured out and
it happens right there even if the next
step is like Hey we're not going to go
forward with this we decided and we do
it but we don't leave things in the air
we don't leave things in a state where
you basically don't know what the next
step is even if there's no Next Step
so that like when you think about that
that makes you move so much faster which
is hey we're going to decide this now
and work on these Now versus hey this is
something that you know we might do and
we're going to work on this like in two
weeks which means that it ends up being
pushed two weeks because when you meet
again in two weeks it's like wait what
did we chat about you know two weeks ago
like which is what we're going to do so
uh that's I think one of the biggest
lessons um from butcherbox and and how
we got to move very very fast initially
and that's something that we definitely
you know taken over to grip I'm imp
implemented here as well what do you
think the biggest mistake so far has
been like everything is this amazing
success story fast growth but like what
are what's something you look back and
you're like yeah you know we we messed
up and we learned from
that
um it's a good question
um I think for me personally uh it's
probably ER like doing too much
initially um
because like I I get so obsessed with
quality work and with A+ work that I
sometimes hold too long to that work and
do it myself but something that I've
learned over time is that you need to
trust the people that you work with to
do A+ work and if you don't do that
they're just never going to grow and
never going to get to do A+ work if they
were not know doing it before and I
think initially for me that's that's one
of the biggest mistakes where I think if
you do that you just end up building you
know a longer term stronger team it
probably takes more investment initially
you know personally by you know like
letting go of something or teaching
something uh to someone but you know
after you get to do that like that's
when you get to exponential
growth when you look at um the pharmacy
space I know that you guys aren't doing
a ton there yet but but I think that
there's a belief that there will be a
big Market there um what will that look
like what are the similarities and
differences to you know D Toc uh kind of
food or or beverage stuff mhm I me you
have all the the weight loss industry is
massive now you know OIC it's has been
blowing up everyone is you know
supposedly trying that and and and
consuming that and the the similarity is
that you get a product of refrigerated
something to a doorstep like it's a it's
a very very similar process I think
regulatory wise it's different on the
pharmacy side of course because you know
everything needs to be checked out by a
pharmacist so you need to have the
infrastructure for that and then
sometimes you can't get some products
from one state to the other as well so
like from that standpoint it's similar
but when you look at the logistics
behind it the decision- making behind it
the customer experience behind it a lot
of it is extremely similar and is your
thought process that uh right now people
obviously are ordering a lot of non-
perishables I would actually argue in
some cities like a New York uh I mean
you see the delivery drivers carrying
hot food around everywhere right and and
so maybe there's not as much hot food
being delivered as non- perishables but
like definitely it's rising very quickly
eventually will cold be the same H I
think it's a it's it's for different
uses and different needs people usually
go to cold food when they want to eat
healthier because they know that they
can get this product to their to their
doorstep and they can then control what
they eat inside their house by either
like they get the ingredients and they
cook it themselves or they have a very
uh strict routine of how they eat with
basically like the meals you know
prepared for them or or almost prepared
for them so that's like one segment of
it the other segment is as we were
talking like the Specialty Products um I
mean we've talked about these my mom's
favorite cake um Lady M um if anyone
from ladym is listening to this please
get in touch with me we've been trying
to get to the CEO for a while but he
he's ghosting me back story on this is
my mom loves this cake this cake is made
in New York and every time that that we
used to come to New York with my mom we
buy this cake for her and now you know
she moved to Miami I moved to Miami
actually not she didn't move to Miami
and every time that she vises me in
Miami I order this cake and it's in the
freezer when she goes there so that's
like the whole other the market it's
like you know special the products like
oh Dam this thing is made in New York
when she comes to Miami I just ordered a
couple days before that and it's just in
the freezer waiting for her prob happy
she's happy yeah um is there other
customers out there that you're like man
we really want to work with uh these
people I know there's a whole bunch of
like you know customers on a list but
like what are like the two or three
dream
customers um Lady M Lady M Lady M and
Lady M
no I'm kidding that would make my my mom
happy um but
um I mean like we really like Innovative
products and Innovative companies one of
the feedbacks that we've gotten from our
customers is
that they like that we move as fast as
they move um which it's definitely
different and new in this industry
so my the companies that I like the most
is companies that you know we complete
their onboarding process for like a week
it's like so fast everything just
happens they get integrated into our API
or Shopify app and everything just
happens so fast so um you know I'm
passionate about those companies because
I think that those are the companies
that are going to succeed and given that
according to the people internally we
company as a service um instead of
software as a service um we like we get
to basically get very like
interconnected with their teams and
their systems and that's what excites me
uh when it comes to to new customers all
right before I let you go uh give me the
like one minute pitch to a customer why
should they use
grip so if you are a direct to
Consumer refrigerated or frozen company
and you want to improve your bottom line
and service your customer better you
need to be working with us because
there's not a single company that we've
worked with where we can't make their
operation better I've been very proud
about this because every time that we
get to chat with someone look to the
data there's always a massive value out
in terms of how they're doing things now
and how they uh would do them with us
and that's two things one you're
starting a new direct to Consumer and a
retailer or two you already have a bunch
of Frozen or refrigerated products in
the mail that you want to basically get
to your customers in a better way what
is the one minute on why people should
come work at
grip if you want to grow uh
professionally personally and you want
to help us build a on in a generation
company H this is this is the place for
you and then uh what is your message to
all the people who think that you can't
be
successful I've had some of those um
I'll keep trying you know I'll keep
trying uh it's I I love it work I mean
you You' you've seen me work this is
something that you know I'm I'm I'm
passionate about and um you know I it's
something that I saw at at my um you
know growing up uh looking at my dad
basically working hours and hours a day
he's a beast yeah he's a beast um there
was things that he liked so like that's
basically what I know how to do so uh
yeah the only thing I'll say about
Juan's dad is uh you warned me uh he he
came to Miami and you told me beforehand
uh you're like look he just he works a
lot and I was like yeah okay whatever
and uh then I saw it in person and I was
like wow I work a lot Juan works a lot
Juan's dad might work longer than both
of us that's crazy yeah it's funny I um
you know like if you grow up in
household where you see your dot work
24/7 there's one or two outcomes one is
you say I don't want to be like the this
guy and I don't want to work so you're
going to like hate work or two you're
going to go and you're going to say Hey
you know this like I want to become this
guy and I look up to this guy so I'm
going to work harder than him I don't
think that I work harder than him by the
way but you know at least I like I got
that you know got the positive impact I
got the positive impact of that and and
not to say that you know you don't need
to take care of like other things right
you know you still have a you know
beautiful family and you need to take
care of that and you need to build
relationships and have experiences and
and you know have friends but if you're
working towards something that you're
really passionate about and that
passion it's not necessarily like the
product but having an impact in the
people that you work with and the
customers and employees and changing
their lives for the better then like
work becomes life and life becomes work
like this thing of work life balance at
that point is irelevant because it's
just you know the same thing that makes
you happy basically well the part that
too that I think um as a parent now uh
there's times where I'm like if I work a
lot this is a good example to a kid and
I and I actually think that like it's is
it's the other end of it where um I
wonder if you did a study of a bunch of
parents like do they end up actually
working harder knowing that their kids
are watching I don't I don't know but
like it I catch myself sometimes being
like it is good that I am working
because my kids will realize that you
know you have to work hard to get things
in life totally I mean I've seen your
kids at the office while you're you know
in meetings that they're just like
around you so you know growing up what
are they going to remember they're going
to like oh you know I I I have this is
like there's this fun office culture
where you know I can be at and have fun
and work and like enjoy the people
around me so you know that experience is
unbeatable in our office in Miami the
kids only wanted to come cuz Juan was
there and he would play soccer with
them he'd never let them win though he
would always make sure he
won awesome all right where do we set
people on the internet and find out more
about grip shipping you know grip
shipping.com uh easiest way and then
companies on link on LinkedIn I'm I'm on
Twitter as well Juan ceso or Juan maso
you can find me on Twitter and Linkedin
as well all right but grip shipping.com
correct I appreciate it very much my
friend you're building a fast growing
company hopefully we do this again in
the future you're doing a billion
dollars in Revenue there you go good to
see you